we've been looking at parallel lines and
the angles that you get
when you've got them and you've got a
line that crosses them and that was the
transversal
with the corresponding angles and they
look like an f so sometimes the f
is backwards and sometimes the f is
upside down but it's still an f kind of
shape
same deal with these alternate angles if
you're looking on the opposite side of
the transversal
you get something that looks kind of
like a z or a backwards z
that's the kind of thing yeah i suppose
it's a bit like a lightning bolt
now the final kind of relationship that
i'm interested in
is this one over here okay now we keep
on coming back to aqr
i want to compare hqr and um
qrc aqr
and qric now look at them with me look
at them with me
clearly clearly they are not
equal right i mean i could try and draw
them so they looked equal
but on this example this angle up here
it's a it's a blunt looking animal right
what's the name for a blunt
looking angle starts with an o
it's obtuse a blunt angle
and obtuse literally just means blunt
whereas
this angle down here right it's not
blunt at all it's quite sharp which is
what we call it
are cute right yeah have you ever
noticed when like um
if you're reading like a pack of panel
or something like that it's like
for acute pain you should die it means
sharp sharp pain okay
so this angle is obtuse this sounds
acute they are not equal
at all but they must have some kind of
relationship
right see here's what i want to look at
we've already established that aqr
is equal to qr
d yes what was the reason what did we
call them
yeah which are uh good they're all
opposite sides of the transversal
they're alternate okay
so i can say angle a q r is equal to n
q r d because they're alternate okay and
if i had time i would write out that
reason
okay but look with me
at let me get another color these two
angles together qrd
and qrc qrd
there's one on this side right and qrc
on the other side okay now thick think
back to when we first started looking at
angles
these two angles are related to each
other they're not vertically opposite
they're next to each other so we give it
a slightly different name do you
remember what we called them
adjacent they're adjacent angles they're
not just adjacent though
they're adjacent along a straight line
okay can you see that they're adjacent
along cd
so therefore i can say that these two
angles they add up to something
what do they add up to 180 degrees
angle qrd plus
angle qrc they add up to
a straight angle which is 180 degrees
okay
but look look look aqr and qrd are the
same
right they're the same so therefore
in this next line here
instead of writing q r d i'm going to
write
a q r because they're the same
they're the same okay so when i add that
to
q r c which was the angle that i was
interested it should still
equal 180 degrees
right can you see that is that all right
let me write down this reason is
important by the way you should probably
have this one down
the reason why they they add to 180
degrees is because
angles on a straight line
on the straight line is cd add to 180
degrees
okay please have that written because
like i said the reason is the important
thing
okay so therefore from there i conclude
that i can i can make that
swap that substitution between these two
angles because they're the same
no that's that thing before a q
r that shows like that's in english it
really throws me off it looks like
it does look like a nail doesn't it so
what i would recommend is you make sure
you write it at it enough of a like
don't write it like this
yeah so it looks like an hour okay now
don't go to it yet
i told you we ran out of time this is
why right i've got to finish this off
these two angles here right have a look
at them oh my god
they're both inside this little box here
right
yes they're both inside so the phrase we
used to say they're both
inside is this phrase we call it
interior angles
because they're both inside both inside
so if you look at the shape that they
form it looks kind of like this
kind of looks like that see how they're
both inside
but they're not the same they're not
equal to each other are they
what are they they're supplementary
corresponding angles they look like an f
okay if you turn around the co-interior
angles they look kind of like a u right
right and that those alternate angles if
you turn them around they kind of look
like an m yes